"SPECIAL REPORT."
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DIGGING IN
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT.
HE WANTS ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
TURNED BACK AT THE BORDER
WITHOUT SEEING A JUDGE AND HE
INSISTS IT'S UP TO CONGRESS TO
ACT QUICKLY TO FIX A BROKEN
SYSTEM.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF ON
THE NORTH ONE TONIGHT.
>> THE TALKS TOXIC ENVIRONMENT
SURROUNDING THIS SUMMER'S
ILLEGAL CRISIS ON THE BORDER
CONTINUES TO BUILD WITH TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS BEING
THROWN OUT OF RESTAURANTS AND OF
THE PRESIDENT WANTING TO THROW
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS OUT OF THE
COUNTRY.
MEETING WITH JORDAN'S
KING TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
FOCUSED ON THE MIDDLE EAST PEACE
PROCESS.
BUT IT WAS AGAIN IMMIGRATION
THAT PIQUED HIS INTEREST IN A
Q&A WITH REPORTERS.
>> President Trump: WE WANT
STRONG BORDERS AND WE WANT NO
CRIME.
STRONG BORDERS, WE WANT NO
THE DEMOCRATS WANT OPEN BORDERS,
AND THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT CRIME.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID HE HAS NO
REGRETS ABOUT SIGNING LAST
WEEK'S EXECUTIVE ORDER TO KEEP
FAMILIES TOGETHER, SHOOTING DOWN
REPORTS THAT HE DID NOT WANT TO
SIGN IT.
HE AGAIN INSISTED THAT IT'S
CONGRESS THAT NEEDS TO ACT TO
FIND A PERMANENT SOLUTION.
>> THE LAWS ARE OBSOLETE,
HORRIBLE HAVING TO DO WITH THE
BORDER IN TERMS OF SECURITY AND
PROBLEM AND A LOT OF THE
PICTURES THEY THOUGHT WOULD USE,
I GUESS THE PICTURES WERE TAKEN
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID TODAY HE
ADMINISTRATION FACED.
ON HIS POLICY OF DETAINING
FAMILIES AND ENDING CATCH AND
RELEASE, THE PRESIDENT GOT SOME
SUPPORT FROM PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY, JAY
JOHNSON.
>> WE BELIEVE IT WAS NECESSARY
CERTAIN ACCOUNTABILITY.
IN MY THREE YEARS WE DEPORTED,
REPATRIATED OR RETURNED OVER A
MILLION PEOPLE.
>> AND I WE CAN TREAT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROPOSED TO
PROCESS.
THE PRESIDENT WROTE, WHEN
SOMEBODY COMES IN, WE MUST
IMMEDIATELY WITH NO JUDGES OR
MANY PEOPLE SAW THAT AS THE
PRESIDENT SCORCHING DUE PROCESS.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT OUR COUNTRY
STANDS FOR.
WE ARE A PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN
EVERYTHING GOOD.
WE DO HAVE A SYSTEM OF LAWS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE HAS ALREADY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE DEPORTED
EVERY YEAR WITHOUT SEEING A
JUDGE.
UNDER U.S. LAW, IMMIGRANTS ARE
SUBJECT TO EXPEDITED REMOVAL,
TAKING TO A BORDER CROSSING IS
RELEASED.
THE PRESIDENT'S IDEA WOULD
EXPAND THAT TO INCLUDE PEOPLE
FROM NONCONTIGUOUS COUNTRIES,
>> THE PRESIDENT WOULD CERTAINLY
LIKE TO SEE MORE EXPEDITED
REMOVAL BUT ULTIMATELY THE
PRESIDENT WOULD LIKE TO SEE OUR
BEGIN WITH.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO FIX OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM COMPLETELY,
NOT JUST TINKER WITH IT.
>> THE THEY TALKED ABOUT A
WEEKEND INCIDENT IN WHICH HE WAS
AND ASKED TO LEAVE THE RED HAND
RESTAURANT IN LEXINGTON,
VIRGINIA.
WE ARE ALLOWED TO DISAGREE BUT
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO SO
IDEAS AND PHILOSOPHY IS
IMPORTANT, THE CALLS FOR
HARASSMENT AND PUSH FOR ANY
TRUMP SUPPORTER TO AVOID THE
PUBLIC IS UNACCEPTABLE.
>> Reporter: AFTER SHE WAS
ASKED TO LEAVE THE "REDHEADED
RESTAURANT," THEY RETIRED BACK
TO WHERE THEY WERE STAYING FOR
THE EVENING AND THEN THE FAMILY
DECIDED TO GO TO ANOTHER
RESTAURANT IN THE AREA.
THEY WERE FOLLOWED IT TO THAT
RESTAURANT BY A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
INCLUDING THE OWNER OF THE     "